this week in two days families will
gather to celebrate thanksgiving and in
contrast to last year many of us will
get to do that in person the holidays
you know is a time to celebrate but as
sunday morning correspondent lee cowan
reminds us it's also a time to remember
the less fortunate and think about ways
to better ourselves and others
[Music]
can you say gobble gobble
remember last thanksgiving most of us
were just thankful 2020 was almost over
this year no more virtual dinners our
thanksgiving traditions have mostly
returned
hi
what do you think
hi
but as we bow our heads in the company
of all of those we care most about
not very far away
are plenty suffering without
those with no shelter who are hungry or
struggling with addiction or mental
health sometimes both
for them thanksgiving day
is just another day
their friends and family
maybe they have none
the unluckiest among them are dreadfully
alone
the feeling surely magnified
imagining the rest of us
gathering together
but the holiday spirit that we hear so
much about isn't some ghostly apparition
at this time of year its touch
can be every bit as real as a handshake
after all no one is forcing us to gather
spare change at a traffic light to give
to the man or woman with a cardboard
sign
nobody insists we rummage through our
closets to find warm clothes to give to
those whom we've never met
thank you you guys have a blessed
thanksgiving
our schedules usually too packed to
volunteer the rest of the year
mysteriously open up
and maybe
we even step foot in a house of worship
for the first time
in a long long while
[Music]
be careful
[Music]
whatever you believe the holiday spirit
to be
it does seem to be tangible it brings
those who are not at our table into
gentle focus
it reminds us
how lucky we are
and it makes all the disparate parts of
our country seem even for a few weeks
like we're gathered around some common
hearth
of course keeping that spirit all year
long isn't easy
maybe that's why every 12 months
we get a chance to try again
[Music]
and we hope you have a very good
thanksgiving happy thanksgiving happy
days
i love a little child's voice it never
ever gets old thank you lee cowan for
that reminder my aunt who told me once
guys that no matter how dark it seems so
i was going through a really dark time
divorce my mom had just done lots of
stuff she said even in the darkest times
you have reason to say thank you seems
hard at that time but i think she's
actually actually right if it wasn't
clear to people those pictures you just
saw were all of the wonderful people
that we work with every day that put
this show on for all of you uh so we're
i'm personally grateful for them because
they make me look good on a daily basis
i know i was thinking why is vlad in the
pictures he sent it in i was like you
got that email too oh i did i'm thankful
for our cbs family and it's been rough
for the last couple of years for a lot
of people yeah but i'm thankful that we
get to talk to and even touch those that
we love yeah awesome stuff